citizens of the
reject Nation it is John and Andrew
Gordon back in the saddle once again to
check out a classic piece of Cinema
starring Denzel and Ethan Hawk it's
Training Day Andrew how are you feeling
man I am excited to see what God Denzel
Washington his best actor that's right
nomination and
win I'm excited I am too I am too Andrew
Used To Be A Beat cop and I was once a
Grizzle detective who got like cast off
the force for doing things my own way so
together I think we have a lot of life
experience to apply to this so why don't
you go ahead before we jump in leave a
like on the video hit the subscription
and notification buttons Bells what have
you thanks to prepper the team who edits
down these videos we love them and
appreciate them greatly and if you guys
want to see the entire Training Day
alongside us with your own copy you can
come over to patre ron.com theal reject
sync up and enjoy every moment that
doesn't make these reaction highlights
it's a blast we also got a bunch of
other shows and movies over there that
we watch with reaction highlights and
watch alongs included Andrew do you have
anything else to say before we do this
yes I do um do you think I'd be the good
cop or the bad cup between you and I you
would be both cops yes that's what I was
hoping both cop I would be the criminal
always do this
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
it's I love the Simplicity of the titles
it almost looks like early digital
editing hey what are you doing
up
[Music]
moow listen everyone's telling you how
lucky you are don't screw this up oh no
that that's a
theme apartment's wide
open get my own division
someday you should see those guys houses
it's got it all mapped out that's right
man career cop wait uh yes sir on your
way to roll call uh yeah I'm on my way
out I thought it would be him listen as
a coffee shop at seventh and wit maybe
we'll do some business you know I just
want to say thank you for giving me
this no no [__] right to that point
it's like I don't need kiss my ass good
morning
sir no thank you man no get some Chow in
you before we go to the office my dollar
I'll take you Ser right fine
don't I don't need the business right
off it's nice here may I read my paper
I'm s sir thank
you you know what I'll get something to
eat no hell no you won't you that up
hazing is going excellently this is a
newspaper right it's 90% [__] but
it's entertaining sure you won't let me
read it so you entertain me with your
[__] tell me a story right now go
it's the problem with news today man we
were on midwatch and oh uh me and Debbie
who's Debbie I'm sorry uh Debbie Maxwell
my training officer uh oh okay okay all
right all right dude it's m
impression Li a license a what her
license was she a a
lesbian have never heard that before
just killing it right now she calls me
over to the vehicle and shows me snub 38
and two shotguns fully loaded and locked
oh [__] she calls our supervisor and I
keep searching I find 500 G of in the
dash
yeah it's amazing that you could be out
there with a fine [__] for a year and
the most entertaining story that you can
come up with to tell me is a drunk
stop it's about the the journey man man
not the start point you ta that
ass tell the truth you know you tapped
that ass you put her in the back seat
bam code X just tell him what he wants
to hear man I got a wife you got a codex
title of your sex t to the right of it
and to the left of it are Pockets right
in those pockets are money pay the
bill who man like how he walks on the
street like you don't give a
[__] so disor gred talking to this guy
yeah I would be so out of my helment
with him so where's the office back at
division in the office
baby that's right
[Music]
[Laughter]
up sure get it must make I guess really
good money as this particular type of
cop yeah do you think he accepts bribes
I no it's not possible Andrew he's
real straight shooter she said training
day today own show me who and What
You're Made Of You don't like narcotics
get the out of my car go back to the
office get a nice desk job you know
chasing bad checks or something you hear
me sir yes sir I don't think this was
the training day he was expecting no he
had this down on his itinerary there was
a pamphlet I want to make the Tex there
you go you can do it stick with me you
can do it unlearn that [__] they
teach you at the Academy though don't
bring none of that [__] in here I will
do anything you want me to do oh he's
like anything yes
Daddy how's your
[Music]
ESP learn that [__] that shit'll get you
killed these [__] out here
plotting all kinds of [__] behind your
back I should have learned Spanish in
school I took Latin you got a kid right
that's right little girl 9 months old I
got four
boys need a son you let me know I hook
your old lady up you know make sure sure
they're boys you got to hide that love
deep inside you you understand otherwise
these out here on the street they'll
find it they'll use it against you and
they will chew you up never wear that
wedding RNG in the
world I'm serious about that all right
all right see they give you these like
abrasive setups and and you know he's
saying these outlandish things but then
you're like oh there's a point you have
to compartmentalize I guess you can't be
in the honeymoon phase and be on the
beat's 17 but he can kill what the best
of work for me Jesus he's he's an
informed teammate you
know he gives me the heads up when big
things are happen and big
transactions small fish in a big pond
but a big boom see that hand in the hand
yeah I saw I saw all right when was the
last time you did a felony stuff a
couple weeks ago good you need practice
they look like college kids I'll get
education
today going to get a bushel of Street
smarts
today
police off put your hands up
whoa oh my God it's Frank Rance sorry
sir shut up too late for that give me
that pipe you got down there on the
floor too quickly my mom give me this I
don't care who my mom now what are you
doing down here you know this is the
gang neighborhood don't you then don't
come down here I see you down here again
I'm going to let the homeboys up the
hill run a train on your girlfriend
in the age of the internet everybody
knows what a train is check that out
it's a shitty dime see the small hairs
undeveloped seeds all the stems in it
see how immature it
is let's roll some of this up and test
it a good narcotics agent should have
narcotics in his
blood what you NOP you are what oh
not why you're Ming something your Jesus
Freak no man I'm not losing my job this
is your job you got to know you have to
understand no
man oh yeah in the middle of the street
just damn if I was a dealer you'd be
dead by now you turn [__] down on the
street and the chief brings your wife a
crisply folded flag what wrong with you
oh out my car go back to the valley
rookie po oh poop I was going to say
freshon he's feeling the peer pressure
now you want me to smoke it I'll smoke
it he's going to cough up a
lung yeah Virgin Love yeah man he said
parked to the middle of the
intersection get the up and just
[Laughter]
wait going to say Sir take as long as
you
want
dude would be stoned for hours virgin
lungs even on crappy crappy buds let's
say I don't know if that's the job you
want to do when you're high this was
just like the day Greg invited me to
start doing reactions with him it's
exactly this is how we react hit it John
hit it John
okay then he pointed a gun learned a lot
though I learned a
lot yeah you're gonna be seeing a bunch
of different
stuff I love the shift in perspective
though yeah just like the things he's
noticing both because of the trip but
also because of just I don't know the
complete rug pool to St yeah I mean also
too you could also look at as like you
can think from a criminal perspective
and how they think too in they're in
that state of mind I guess Mass size hit
you took dog when was the last time you
smoked weed never the um 12th grade you
know you like to get wet
though what's wet but naked
e dust
PCP
Primos that's what you had what what no
just now oh my God it's everything oh
dude he would be so out of his mind
that's why I was wondering why the
Distortion was like this crazy oh my
goodness well they've done a good job
escalating it yeah
[__] why did you do this to me H you an
adult man told you to smoke that what
the
what like I put a gun in your head oh
yeah it definitely didn't do that damn
that's kind so smart yeah this guy is
ruthless and cunning and he's so well
written to did David a is this the movie
D David a wrote I think you're right but
I'm not 100% sure but I believe you are
correct I don't know if he directed this
but it's hard to believe fuka directed
but it's hard to believe the writer this
is the director of su it's quite even
though I know Warner Brothers really
messed with that
film brother get your
ass right how treat you give me a p oh
dang I couldn't tell who was it's stick
oh oh okay Glen right hey you're
probably right just a little bit younger
than uh when Daredevil was but I think
you're right
yeah dead medicine up in
you yeah sober up would you where' you
grow up North Hollywood hey last name ho
ho strong safety North Hollywood High
huh that's right what how did you know
that how did you know that I follow all
the good players uh it's such a small
City you know of
course here's a joke boy man walks out
of his house on his way to work sees
this snail lying on his porch Shucks it
over the roof into the backyard snail
lies there
dying finally after about a
year the little guy crawls back on the
porch I think I know where this is going
walks out of his house on his way to
work and he says the [__] your problem
yeah
yep classic somebody I know stole that
from this movie figure that choke out
you figure the streets
out oh I already figured them out it's
all about smiles and cries you got to
control your smiles and cries because
that's all you have and nobody can take
that away from you there's a bar there a
lowke keeper you were just like him what
same silly ass look and everything
saving the god world yeah yeah that now
have some smiles and
cries I'm less than a year away from my
dream Philippine Islands here I come and
I ain't never coming back that's right
let me go with you you're invited I hope
they ride off into the sunset I'm the
zigzag man are you I'm a cop man watch
out all right don't shoot nobody once
you get that be in you man that'll give
you
bance
yeah sober up man I'm curious how this
is going to affect home life this is
going to change him oh man he's going to
be the same wonderful person he was when
we met him at the beginning of the film
stop the car man stop the car stop stop
the car I saw something oh no hey hey
hey oh jeez dude o love how awkward his
posture is oh my God police officer get
away from the girl get away from whoa
damn whoa not not a bad
roll damn
dude
whoa curious what she was doing need
RoboCop in here Dead or Alive you're
coming with me yo
why you not in school I was just going
to a ditch party you almost became a
part of the ditch party yeah we're going
to cut him loose well you want to beat
him up go get down protect and serve
brother I got a punch him back at home
to just don't play by the
rules what are you talking about this is
textbook Andrew textbook big boys have
you grab your ankles man my [__] I know
people that's how it starts who do you
know yeah oh [__] huh huh oh damn
whoa you like the young girls that's
your Mo no that's what you like is you
like young girl
whoa me to your [__] is that what you
said to
me that's not what you said to me so I'm
lying am I lying no huh where is oh put
your pants down w
list that you want
whoa close your
eyes close your eyes it's
got It's got like have more pressing
business oh man that was
intense that girl's 14 she all woman
though man you tax for day
man that scene had very much like am I a
clown do I amuse you kind of energy like
he does have that kind of like Joe peshy
wild for sure that was for sure good
good Fell's Vibe I mean those guys
deserved it but damn that was
intense yeah it's weird and that's a
great seed to kind of ride the line CU a
lot of people I bet would probably split
between the two approaches you know they
had have killed you without hesitating
that's why they belong in prison for
what they got beat down they lost their
Rock they lost their money yeah but
they're going to keep doing it again
good guys they die first right to
protect the Sheep you got to catch the
wolf and it takes a wolf to catch a wolf
you understand I mean that's a fair
point too I mean he's making a fair
point that I agree with but I still
think those other guys belong in prison
too I think they're both making good
points don't play the middle Andrew I
always play the middle John matter what
I say you did the right thing yeah I
noticed you applied that uh that choke
holdo huh I thought that was a no no
procedure
boy snake man you did what you had to do
that's
right wolf become the wolf
yep no I said a wolf not a
rooster I thought I was a rooster you
know
just it's okay Maverick you up your
street IQ you're going to do some damage
out here I guarantee
you good choice words yeah but what's
going to happen to your soul in the
process nothing thing Andrew he's going
to be
fine is that is that Snoop oh my God I
got Snoop in this uh crack
crack nobody says crack man what I look
like a sucker
you youie
yeah yo give me a break man hey yo slow
up slow up make so much hard all right
just calm down calm
down you must have to learn a little of
a lot of languages working this job he's
adaptable no rocks no rocks man but I
found this man that ain't mine man that
mother planted that [__] on me man put
me in the front seat with him and I bet
I whoop his
ass where the rocks at I ain't got
nothing on me I gave it up dog where the
rocks at oh no open your mouth what what
is you a doctor now I'm a dentist open
your mouth oh your partner already
didn't search me I'm straight yeah okay
you got to pain to take a note with in
your handy notebook huh nothing man come
got
nothing
wow whoa now what is that mother crack
that's right Jimmy Crack Corn one whoa
that crack and a gun now you know with
your record you can get 10 years per a
bullet do you know that now you GNA give
me a name now wo he's a master
interrogator name s man that's all the I
know man [__] sand man is it Flint Marco
I was gonna say Thomas Hayden Church
that was a crazy interrogation scene and
I hope they shot it with a bunch of
different wigs just for coverage just
you know for the rap party yeah I need a
res on a sand man uhhuh
that stuff doesn't fly anymore man shov
a pan down what what if that guy
complain he's gonna file a formal
complaint tell him big SC dog sent you
yeah you can see that complaint a cop
shoved a pen in my mouth and crack came
out this also has like a western flare
to it too in a way buddy cop meets a
western cop neon Noir Western yeah
yeah you'd feel the heat the heat is on
John he that rhymed hey you got bars
Andrew here to serve this war come on
man we can't do that hell yeah we can we
the police we can do we want to do why
we just get a real war listen we're
trying to get [__] done all right just
stand over there and don't get jeez
they're going to knock on the door and
go sahor definitely he loves movies LA
PD open
up ain't even up here right we got to
search one unlock the door please
man
whoa wow is anybody in the house my
nephew Demitri he in the bedroom he 10
years old oh man god artw scene is
intense yeah I was noticing dude this is
hilarious what are you talking it's a
riot every uh I was noticing that
artwork
too just feels like every moment
something could pop off that's what
happens in comedies I want to see that
warning yeah well my partner has it
he'll be out within a sec go your back
up uh uh uh who is that voice sounds
familiar to me how you doing over there
huh you cool you cool come on oh dude
it's no don't leave him hanging no I
know he's pointing a gun at you guys but
don't leave him that was very cringe
Demitri Close Your Eyes the Punky ass
cop is going to shoot me sit down right
now okay okay okay everything is fine we
made a mistake oh good oh jeez I want to
see that God War you go let's
go
hopins you better give me my money back
mother you ain't no police D Jack what
over there looking
pretty oh
[__] of course of
course
oh jeez
wow jeez man like just avoiding the
crossfire alone seems like a hazard I'm
going to be on the 6:00 newses in an
orange jumpsuit and handcuffs because of
you okay man with the scandals and
whatnot it is open season on Miss cond
oh times do not change he took him there
to give him a really tough situation to
lock down see if he could do it got both
a kid and somebody like yelling in your
face what are you talking about there
was nothing tough about that it was easy
and smooth as come this is most of my
social interaction say you're serious
about doing some good in the real world
and this is the place to learn but if
this kind of [__] shakes you up maybe
you ought to go back to your division
you know PR The Watch Commander give you
a nice job light and
Flair you got to decide whether you're a
wolf or a
sheep she she get your
rink or go give him a wonder how many
people got that tattoo after this movie
that one or the one from Starship
Troopers quite a good amount I see a
wolf in every man I ever met and I see a
wolf in you Stones you hear a lot of
murder investigations lead right here
one way in one way out you don't never
come up here without me you hear me a
lot a lot a lot of
red how you doing
man flipping pigeons want to let
everybody know I'm here damn who keeps
the
pigeons it's a lot of great color
coordination in these
scenes people working up on the roof too
been want to tell you man appreciate
what you did for my nephew you better
call
me man I'm sick of this [__] man stand
at
[Laughter]
me dude I always love love you know
don't worry about shots like that from
up
above
mommy whoa hello hey Mendes yeah new guy
J hi nice to meet you come in welcome to
my house oh no it's like this isn't Ryan
Gosling no no no no no no no no no it's
like I thought I told you to bring me a
ryin gosling looking fella now this is
all El Salvadorian food thank you it
looks great and so do you I have to
go that was the subtle way of saying
we're going to go play Nintendo in the
other room right yeah he loves games man
it's most of what Denzel does throughout
this movie it's just high scoring let's
go got a Mee in 15
minutes forget that let's
go a
God how how long was he in there for
he's taking care of business got get
that high score like he said
St this this kiddo I feel like it is my
there's just enough Spanish in there I
didn't know to yeah it's either his
dad's not there or that's his kid my new
guy who works on my squad Jake Hoy
Captain L Jacob
you ever need to talk to the fed you
talk to him first good man he can take
your back for you kid died is that Tom
barer and those high dollar theft cases
for the French poodle crowd you know if
you lose a Picasso he'll find it for you
a die Trine he's a good man pleas to
meet you good oh no look a
disappointment I don't talk to dead man
ain't dead yet quite a long face Doug
huh why is he so afraid to speak his
mind serial burglar sing s was today
judges female Landers yeah I know
Landers she's a sharp
lady oh no I want a woman version of
training day that's the Remake he's
waiting to give a statement so he shoves
his hand down his pants comes out with a
Gob of extra chunky
GIF oh yeah now he's looking the judge
right in the eyes licks his fingers
clean oh yeah that's comedy boy you
can't prison orders him to psychiatric
she fell for it time she found out it
was sandwich Spar the order was signed
the guy's been
[Laughter]
transferred jeez yeah give him credit
though [__] he work the system deserves
his freedom yeah give him credit that's
the system's responsibility guy the
street and I'm going to do him whoa the
Russians don't care if you have a badge
they'll whack you you would have hop a
jet out of here you got tangled with the
mob it's cash in an account one of my
old ones my first one look the guy's a
high security risk anyway if I'm not
around who's going to keep him off the
radar just tags him that's all oh what
is his name guys are these guys are all
character that's Raymond Barry I believe
and then the guy with the goatee I
forgot that actor's
name what's
up oh it's the bad guy in The Mask you
got the pick and shovels you're in the
truck want to dig a ditch n you are dig
through the ditches isn't burn it's all
good legit signed by the judge okay
thanks to the Sandman now listen up he
gives us [__] boom we're giving him lead
let's do this right so we can all go
home and do the wife or the girlfriend
thing all
right oh is that the villain from uh
Legend of Zoro this guy right
here up down the flo what wait oh is
that oh hey new guys watch it you moov
oh no what yeah I'm on you know what
you're doing son what that's for
you I supposed to do this wipe my
ass oh good shot they just want tax you
a little [__] what happens to me I
promise you you never have to go back to
prison sorry orders is orders dog that
sucks right
here the Los Angeles Chainsaw
Massacre Oh yeah we've struck gold El
Diablo El Dorado I mean well you know El
Diablo D David a Suicide Squad it works
think about it it was a happy accident
ohoo yeah jackpot the IRS are friendly
this time of year4 million dollars you
holding right there in your hand million
in here damn first time you're not
comfortable I'll hold it for you
what about you are you comfortable oh
I'm comfortable how's your comfort level
I'm very comfortable John and I are
comfortable too we'll take his we'll
take his well we're here we helped don't
touch a thing
evidence jeez
man I'm sure this job is everything he
dreamed of so patronizing Hey
Jake shoot him well you want me to shoot
him yeah come on kid come
on hey close the
lines this sucks J you think the line
has been reached
yeah pow boom youngsters these days huh
you're not going to shoot them
give you took Fire coming through the
door I need some time off watch Shad all
right yeah we definitely don't want to
definitely don't want to damage the
shades okay all right you ready Kiss Me
Baby One
yeah you all right literally what they
did with the one thing that was what
they did Allen Rick Die Hard Mark and
Paul you kick the door Jeff's the first
one through Roger opens Fire Hits Jeff
twice
right wonder if he's still feeling
comfortable our new guy Hoy he's in
second drops Roger with some fine
shotgun work who shot Roger wow new guy
came in Spring Point okay Amy this
time a metal of battor for this yeah
good didn't shoot him good job Hoy you
did a Los Angeles Police Department
narcotics officer was killed today
serving a highrisk warrant in Echo Park
give me the [__] oh boy the officer is
survived by his wife and infant child
you get the picture yeah I got the
picture whoa dude that's what I'm
talking about Jake my are y'all watching
this that's it it'll be my pleasure to
put a high shock in that
M let's everybody just take a deep
breath and just diffuse this thing you
hear me Jake you can't pull this [__] on
me man I didn't sign up for this what a
mess that's an order put them
down I'm white knuckling here this
dude's like called the damn ambulance
five proven decorated Officer says that
you're the shooter the investigators are
going to want to pull a tube of your
blood to check for intoxicants what are
they going to find Jake yeah you've been
smoking PCP all day yep
damn I've been planning it all week son
oh boy he's got
him [__] oh boy he's good if you're cool
you're a hero you're a virgin shooter
above suspicion we need to just kill
your boy right now and say Roger got him
coming through the door oh boy he's good
this is a good man right he's got the
magic eye I can feel just had little
freak up don't don't don't come with the
compliments man don't come with the
sweet talk he's a master manipulator
this place is going to be overrun with
blue suits go outside clear your head or
shoot
me yeah he's got him Jake's got to come
up with a plan now to get him that man
was your friend and you killed him like
the fly because he knows my first name
this is the game I'm playing his ass
that's my job that's your job yeah I
watch that sucker operate with impunity
for over 10 years and now I got it woof
the shit's chess it ain't checkers
yeah
bars I believe him but he's manipulating
him all movie let's go down down to the
station you talk to my guys stand and
he'll walk you through what you got to
say to the DA guys okay just what I
thought he was having like an honest
real moment I don't
know dude yeah he's been manipulating
him from a trinity of bull from the
moment he had that newspaper in his hand
he's been manipulating him oh yeah he's
he's been running the whole movie
it's a master class performance but of
manipulation too as well as acting what
the hell we doing now foring of mine up
in Chino I promise that take care of the
family for bring up some food you know
stuff like that got to help out the
family this might be the most
interesting day of this man's
life maybe top top
five whoa is that Cliff Curtis is it oh
wow it is ah dang
first movie I ever saw with him was a
year after this in one of my least
favorite Arnold sportsenegal
damage I did very much dislike that film
one of the few Arnold films but none
more than everyone's favorite one Batman
and Robin kick some ice chill John all
right chill I'm going go to the Head
okay I'm going be two seconds We Roll
said the heater was on so it's my second
Batman let me get the CD player oh my
God I was literally just wondering if
that guy would make an appearance steal
again sniper D oh and it's Tuco damn
your gone holes underneath your shirt
I'm what is it like a 380 stainless 9 mm
bar like like like this one
here I seen this one almost see
yours it's nice to see him like in a
film film are you saying Bruce Al Mighty
and Fast and Furious are not film films
I mean the butt monkey is the height of
Cinema yes
but up with this H know
hell yeah as you aim kind of like
[Laughter]
that yeah all right I got to go yo Lonzo
kick back and party e there nothing out
there for
you oh no what what you jacked Roger
last the fool huh alono I think he's a l
down dirty ruthless by the way but I
like that I like that this uh reminded
me a little of uh crease I like that I
like that last week in Vegas some
Russians starts talking [__] alono he
just sna eat his ass and death Alonzo
he's into the Russians for a million
they gave Alonzo till tonight to pay up
good thing he got his blood money cuz
there's a crew on standby if he don't
turn up downtown with the cash by
midnight and not a minute after he's
dead had your [__] pushed in your [__]
pushed in you ever had a monkey come out
your butt had my [__] pushed in oh yeah
man I had my
[__]
bro saw him in a coffee shop once this a
very interesting energy did you see a
[__] get pushed in yes that's what he
was doing with the
c what the oh put the wrong kind of
milk
ah
oh
boy damn man close the door it's going
to be
low hold up B let me get his money first
yeah hold
up was that the 14-year-old's wallet oh
no hey Smiley you going to trip out is
that your little cousin or what e what
the tell tell him what you
did
no tell him what you did
wow that's crazy I found it I give it I
found it because that girl is being I
saw the drug addicts attacking her and I
stopped him man I swear to God don't Li
me she was
being and I stopped her wow I'm going to
get to the bottom of your [__] she's
my cousin she's a civilian a right
involving her no her that's crazy I did
not think that was coming back around
cops talked to you today no no yeah tell
me what happened okay don't [__] me
I got jumped by these two crackheads
today you got jumped well I think they
wanted to like me or something I don't
know nothing happened okay cuz this cop
came he kicked their asses like that
this car what he look like um he was a
white boy wow we're going to talk more
about this later okay all right oh
that's amazing blast him or what he
saved your cousin of course you're not
was telling the
truth listen sorry you're part of the
family now thanks for getting my cousins
back here put this on your head mess up
my
floor you know this [__] was just
business
right oh you better eyes all right now
you get Denzel man after what he just
did Ethan hog is a great casting choice
for this oh perfect like everyone's been
great obviously D is like obviously
ciece of course but Ethan is fantastic
too is is that uh Eva lendas his place
he's going
to probably
yeah oh Terry Cruz I thought that was
the back of his head earlier I thought
that was too yeah it's got a very
recognizable I was about to say it but I
was like I don't want I'm here for
Alo well they do hate him so they're
going to let him pass yeah
yeah all right we respect the Crazy on
You yeah
hey is your dad home in the bedroom oh
man I think that answers the question of
it's his dad I want you to find a good
hiding spot do you have a favorite one
the class stay in
here I have oh
God stomach is in knots right now yeah
definitely got a lump in my throat right
now
too
you against the wo you passed the test
you're a knock you're in jeez dude what
can you prove huh nothing where's your
evidence huh it's right
there whoa damn jeez on a swivel that
was a scar esque move from Lion King
throwing the ash at his face pocket sand
I see
you
remember that fool in the wheelchair how
you think he got
there talk about Snoop Dog like that oh
no damn it you see what I see Jake job
number one preserve life Wow Los using
your son like that dude we walking out
of here
together
no
noi
no no
no jeez he's got an appointment with the
Russians
jeez
Who
ah spikes
everywhere God Tom Cruz makes those
jumps look a lot easier than they they
are you got to get your parkour skills
on point
whoa
oh
[Applause]
jeez oh
yeah
everybody just minding their own
business yeah it's like just another day
whoa oh I thought he was going over the
roof too
yeah jump onto the hood of the car
welcome to the party
pal you called it not bad I wanted to
say that though welcome to the party pal
that would have made it not meta or
anything
oh
[Music]
jeez
ah it's no fun when the rabbit has a gun
is it my
[__] oh my God first D put one in his
head I'll make you a rich man problem is
they all hate you what you going to do
you going to shoot me you going to bust
your cherry killing a
cop jeez man it's in his pocket like
it's a wallet give me J give me hit me
come on hit me doing his little Heath
Ledger somebody dropped this fool for me
yeah oh boy is he going to hit Denzel
nope yeah
H you got us Twisted Homie we got to put
your own work around here wow and you
ain't going to do a damn thing cuz you
ain't going to shoot no cop in the back
are
you jeez and I'm going to get that gun
and then I'm going to get that money I
don't believe you got it in you Jake I'm
going to go get it right
now boy please Jak give me that money
it's not going to happen Jack me now you
going to take my own money from me huh I
told you that's my evidence you want to
go to jail you want to go
home gotcha damn give me the money let
me go
home that's right come
on you're going home to
jail go ahead and bounce homie get up
out of here we got your back n damn J
come back
here God man you disloyal fool ass [__]
made Punk
yay what a weasel I need my money that's
literally what you did to him at that
house what a weasel you think you can do
this [__] Jay you think you can do this
to
me you [__] will be playing
basketball in Pelican Bay when I get
finished with you 23-hour lock down
you'll never see the light of who the
you think youing with I'm the police I
run [__] here you just live here oh dude
go walk wait cuz I'm going to burn this
[__] down King Kong ain't got
[__] on me I mean he right he don't
that's the line boy oh damn oh what a
day a day
day oh dude oh
wow oh he's got no
money is this the Russians yeah oh no
what have you got for us police officer
where is the
money oh
damn oh oh no oh my
God
[__] oh
boy all
wow oh
man
you made the RoboCop reference earlier
that was just like Kenny in the
boardroom in Robocop or like Sunny
Corleone man I guess yeah you can say
that in Godfather
yeah
damn King Kong did not have [__] on this
guy narcotics officer was killed today
serving a highrisk warrant near
LAX officer Alonzo Harris was survived
by his wife and
wow
off I wanted to see her say honey how
was your first day is that just to Echo
his mock police report at the end of
that wow written by David a solid job of
writing by David a and uh did he did he
also I know he directed Suicide Squad
and again obviously I know Warner
Brother not to get into a he started
directing yeah but did he write also was
in s or oh I think so yeah of course I
know everyone has can have a bad day at
work and obviously I blame Warner
Brothers more than I blame him but no
let's make the training day review about
let's do it about suicide squ but no
seriously solid job by David a like I
give him he's also a co-producer too but
like this is a master class in how you
in a character study of Master
manipulation of like his uh what was
Denzel Washington's character name again
I'm
Alonzo sorry I mean his character was
very he was captivating I mean like when
you want like there's a lot of things
he's saying where you're like [__] like
I don't want to agree with him but I'm
agreeing with him but then like but damn
it he's pulling manipulation tactics at
the same time too I'm like well yeah and
I'm more on Ethan Hawk side and like but
again it's just and the performance from
Denzel Washington like brought the
character to life I mean you can always
write something something on paper and
go this is pretty good what I wrote but
like you need an actor to bring it to
life at the same point and obviously
denzo I I don't need actors we got AI we
don't need actors but I mean that was
Macy Gray I should have said I knew it
was her voice was Macy Gray and
Spider-Man was that the the singer or
yeah okay three I think Spider-Man one I
thought oh maybe you're right I'm not
sure she's in one of them yeah the fair
whatever no gami that guy um anyways the
point I'm making is is I I I thought I
mean Denzel obviously is the standout I
mean I just the the way his character is
written like you you can't take your
eyes off the screen in every moment of
dialogue the dialogue is just so damn
crisp in this film it's so well written
and again Denzel just does a great job
of bringing this manipulative evil
character to life on the screen and like
what the life of of a narc uh Detective
narcotics narcotics narcotics cop cop um
what they go through on a daily basis
yeah whatever it is um what they go
through on a Day-Day basis um and then
also it was an interesting take from
Ethan Hawk's character someone who's you
know akin to getting into this like hey
I'm looking forward it's my first day
and then like hey you don't know what
what this life is like let me show you
you know the the what what it's all
about and uh kind of manipulating him
and showing him the rough beats if you
will and you know kind of
like kind of get you know losing his
soul in the process but he didn't allow
it and I I just I really liked his
character a lot too obviously I I I
thought Denzel just I mean he's the
standup but I really liked Ethan Haw I
thought they had such incredible
chemistry but what do you think of the
film no yeah they they have to and yeah
it's a film where like the Denzel
Washington obviously he is the the
biggest flashiest and not in a b yeah
he's just he is the force of nature at
the center of everything and then you
need somebody like Ethan Hawk who I'm
curious to kind of go back and look at
what his film MOG would have been at the
time because I imagine this was probably
a bit of a turning point for his career
as well partly because yeah it became
such uh an iconic piece of Cinema but
also you need somebody with that fresh
face and who it's like I think of uh you
know the before midnight Trilogy um or
before Sun whatever you want to call it
you know I think of him from Like
Richard link lader things and things
that are you know just less Gruff and
less harsh and gritty than this and the
way he encapsulates yeah that
fresh-faced optimism that's then
tempered over the course of the movie I
think is is really fascinating and and
wonderfully played because too I mean
you know Denzel is great because at that
like he's they're good at introducing
you to him because like from the second
they meet and and the movie has like a
really nice sort of um just like
naturally unfolding feeling to the
pacing and the storytelling where it
just feels like yeah just new
developments just keep on happening and
it almost reminded me of like instead of
like a Tarantino movie where or you
think of like a reservoir dogs or
something which like you know you start
with like the plan going arai this is
like you're slowly watching them build
tension until the plan you know until
[__] just keeps hitting the fan in
increasing ways and and I guess the
point I was starting to make was that
yeah like at the beginning of the movie
you start to tap into him and you're
like okay maybe this guy you know has a
bit of an abrasive demeanor or he has
you know a bit of an off color sense of
humor but you know yeah he has a point
that you need to understand the real
language and the real currency of the
place that you are trying to inhabit and
enact a change in you can't look at
everybody from the outside you know you
have to know and understand the
experiences of the people that you're
you know dealing with and obviously
through Alonzo's eyes oftentimes that
means for worse but you know like it's
great because
the further we get the more you realize
oh no this is a guy who will do anything
he can to make it in the world it's just
lucky he wound up you know in law
enforcement but you know when he's
appealing to uh hoy's humanity and stuff
like that like there are these little
tiny moments where it thinks where it
feels like oh no he's he's really
getting honest with him yeah and then
he'll come back around like the second
you're like no yeah like it's it's well
written and performed and paced and
directed because so many times during
the film I would have that moment where
I'm like you know this guy's a real
Great Character he's got some real
questionable morality but I get the the
point of what he's trying to say and
here finally is like a nugget of truth
and the second you start to think oh
maybe he's actually being you know again
open and and vulnerable or or you know
himself about something then that new
piece of flattery and manipulation comes
around and you're like ah I don't know
if anything I saw was authentic from
this guy and so yeah that's that's a
great performance in and of itself and
then Ethan Hawk is a character that you
can really identify with CU he's most of
us yeah yeah definely relate to him yeah
he's he's got a good heart and a good
moral compass and yeah he's willing to
step somewhat outside the lines but not
you know everybody finds Their Own Line
for how far they're willing to go into
the depths and I feel like by the end of
it you know while I don't think he'll
pursue this career path anymore
necessarily it is like he's learned to
apply his moral instincts to the harsh
reality that he has seen and he's come
to the conclusion that yeah you do have
to compromise and you do have to you
know uh stare into the abyss a little
bit and and you know wear the Wolves
clothing but you can draw the line as to
how far into the true crime and into you
know being just the same as the people
you're looking down on that you want to
go you know yeah absolutely uh really
quickly just um before I touch on that I
thought that was I don't know if you saw
it said on the stunt on the stunt people
it said David air I I had no I had no
idea he was into stunts um cool I mean I
don't know David a seems like he's had I
don't know what his like upbringing was
like but it seems like he that's amazing
that you can do writing co-producing
directing and you can do like dude does
it all I mean again I wasn't not to get
into Suicide Squad stuff again but I I
that movie I feel so bad for him because
that movie like eclipses every other
otherwise relatively wellik I'm just
saying in general the dude can do it all
is all I'm I actually know that guy tier
Turner stun coordinator I actually used
to work for him anyways um point I'm
making is I agree with a lot of what you
said um it was interesting to see like
you know the when you were talking about
uh Alonzo just like appealing you know
to uh uh Jake Ethan Hawk's character
just trying to appeal to his humanity
and then like oh this is like a you know
just I was like you know what at this
point again it was great character
moment just for him but I'm like at this
point he's manipulated him one to for me
personally I'm like he's manipulated him
one too many times I'm like I've I'm not
falling me personally I'm like I'm not
falling for it anymore but he's good
like I I get where he's what he's trying
to do with him and he's he's got uh Jake
by the balls at this point no pun
intended but um the the planning that he
came up with too like from the moment he
had that newspaper in his hand he knew
exactly how to push Jake's buttons and I
loved like the way he was scheming and
the elabor uh the elaborate planning he
came up with just in terms of the whole
day just and as the pl as the film was
unfolding just as we learned he owed
money to the Russians the millions of
dollar whatever he owed and then you
know he got him to smoke the PCP or
whatever and then he'd know like okay so
once I get him uh once I get this money
I'm gonna put him in here and have him
do this so that he's going to have to go
along with the plan otherwise he's going
to be it's just it was really elaborate
and I love that like even though again I
was not rooting for Alonzo in any way
shape or form like I like intelligent
villains like again I I'm not I'm not Ro
again not rooting for them but it's fun
to watch them on screen like it's
something where I enjoy it's satisfying
to watch yeah he's like the Devil he's
like you know he he at least through the
the lens of the of the Jake character
it's like yeah you meet a guy who's your
Superior who's kind of living the career
that you're trying to get to
and who is always kind of I don't know
he's always like messing with you but
then all of a sudden you'll find
yourself in like the worst situation and
then he's stringing you along and uh and
just yeah like they're they're back and
forth and to like the incredible
Supporting Cast this was a really well
cast movie too and I feel like there
were too many character actors to name
um and I mean you had stop dog and Dr
Dre Curtis Curtis was in there gami has
been in so many other things and like
tons of other characters
this was really an ensemble and and like
the way that they chose the casting you
have like the upper table guys who he
meets with uh in the the restaurant to
like really kind of give us the scoop on
his you know mess up with the Russians
and everything and then you have yeah
just like so many incidental characters
and sure like these people were I think
a lot of these actors were either
getting established or you know sort of
on that rise certainly of the of the you
know
I mean younger cast but you know like
people in like the Ethan Hawk angel
raage on the cast um but yeah like just
so much life and like that moment at the
end when they have that final showdown
in the neighborhood and everyone is
watching this happen and this and it's
this guy they were taunting moments ago
and just like you know you get the the
whole idea of quote the streets to sound
as white as possible you know you get
the lay of the land and the sort of idea
of what you're dealing with so so much
through Alonzo's perspective that when
you get to that final moment and you see
his power removed and you see just how
he just constantly just at every single
turn is just finding a new way to Wi
wiggle his way out of the situation like
you see kind of a more Stark view of you
know the community kind of servicing
itself almost it's like everybody's
finally realize like yeah we don't like
this this you know rookie cop who keeps
coming here either we're you know we're
we're hitted against each other by the
system and yet we can tell somehow that
this guy is probably doing this for
something outside of both like your
average police reason and your average
you know crime corruption reason like
and when that guy puts the gun down it's
a great symbolic moment because it could
have been really cheesy it could have
been like an Oh Captain My Captain like
oh everybody in the neighborhood just
hoists this this rookie cop up on their
shoulders but like it really did feel
like a western Showdown or something
yeah
yeah we're not going to into this system
of corruption and and exploitation that
you have as much as you pretend to be
our friend that you have us under the
boot heel of so much of the time you can
fight for yourself like you know this
situation has to play out but even that
has this sort of weird uh almost I don't
know mystical sort of slight peripheral
magic about it where it's like yeah it
is both
you know like I'm equipping you to
handle your own [__] but also I'm I'm
laying down the sort of statement on all
of our behalfs that we don't want to be
a part of this anymore and if he's going
to help remove you then then he's good
by us and like that was a really
striking moment oh definitely among so
many striking moments I mean this this
again you know it's post Tarantino a bit
I mean it's got yeah like it's very own
crime informed tone and grittiness and
harshness and realism but it's super
dialogue driven all the characters and
places you go are distinct but they all
really feel like these different parts
of LA and uh and I got to I mean like
hats off like I understand why this
launched both uh Antoine fuka and David
a because like the com this is one of
those pieces where like everything comes
together the locations the costuming the
color choices the performances and the
the writing feels like it was authored
by I know David A's like a white guy but
like I I feel like it's it it has that
sense of somebody who has lived in in
aspects of this world at least and done
a good amount of their research it seems
like and uh and yeah like it had a
rhythm and it had a color to the
dialogue and to the scenery and to the
storytelling but without feeling like
another Tarantino joint or something or
a Tarantino wannabe but having yeah all
these different elements of that stuff
the more subversive stuff that was
coming up in the 90s and then your crime
movies and your Noir stuff and your
cowboy stuff and and yeah there's like
so much kind of packed into it and it's
uniquely very sort of urban laay yeah
and you know just adding to what you
just said I thought a lot of the scenes
too were extremely intense I mean you
got that one scene where the two guys
were about to you what they were about
to do with the c with Cliff Curtis's
cousin and then he was like uh he was
pointing the gun at you know his bottoms
and like like just scenes like that were
extremely intense and then and building
us up with moments like that so many
people probably fantasize about if
they're considering like going into you
know policing of any kind yeah and also
too just building off of that too from
that intensity I I love again what David
a did just usually I'm able to pick up
like on foreshadowing stuff and when he
picked up that that that pink wallet and
uh I wasn't even thinking in the back of
my head like how's this going to turn
like why is he even picking up that ping
wall what's that going to turn into
later in the film like usually I'm able
to pick up on little he's get shot and
the pink wallet's going to save him I
mean usually I would have said something
funny like that in a way they kind of
did that but without it actually being
like he puts it in his breast pocket you
know yeah no for sure but again and I
know we did talk about really quickly
briefly in the in in our reaction but
like I know like La is a ginormous place
and of all the places for Alonzo to
bring him to it was her cousin of but
again it works within the constraints of
the story that I've had like I said I'm
sure you I've had many times where I'm
like something random and like how did
this person of all places go here things
have happened in my life randomly so I I
truly do buy that honestly yeah it has
enough I think the the rest of the movie
is is kind of harsh and tempered enough
that that little piece of magic helps or
at least I justify that little piece of
magic because it is like a slight moment
of that in yeah an otherwise very
grounded experience that also hearkens
to that weird magic that can sometimes
happen in life and to the fact that
there is a different kind of morality
than just the one that's being posed by
uh Alonzo's character like these guys
they they they are too part of this
greater sort of Underworld business and
yeah there is some sense of you know you
looked out for us though you know and
it's such a great tense scene and and
such a I thought they I'm glad they
didn't jerk us around with that like oh
no she going to tell the truth like it
played out very realistically but also
with a great breathless catharsis also
too I'm glad like because he was being
manipulated by Alonzo old film one of
the good things he was able to do like
being himself like it was kind of like
the Mr Miyagi thing in Cobra Kai where
he was in uh okanawa you know where uh
you know so the well no what I was
saying no what I was saying is you know
put a little good out in the world some
good will come back that that type thing
where you know he was able to do a good
thing there and then that kind of saved
his life in the end there type of thing
is what I meant to say there and as much
as and as much as Alonzo is like know
this isn't what we deal with you know
you leave that to the to the garbage men
or whatever at the same time it's like
no the it it bolsters the Jake
character's again sense of morality like
no you know yeah you do have to get your
hands dirty you do have to show that
you've been through some stuff and you
have dirt on your face but uh you can
you know reap a little bit of that good
that you sew if you make an effort to
sew it and uh I think I think yeah this
this is a very rich this movie has a
little bit everything cuz yeah it's like
it's super edgy and harsh and like there
aspects of it it almost reminded me of
Boogie kns a little bit in the way that
like it's not there's not as much of a
rise and fall in terms of like this is
awesome but there is like a mounting
sort of set of circumstances that once
they reach the moment where they kill
Roger I thought that was like we're
getting towards the end of the movie but
really that's just a turning point in
Ethan Hawk's character where now we have
to go through the true descent you know
the true fall after the rise he he's had
enough been fall since certainly from
the we watching alono kind of reach a
Zenith and then a great and uh yeah I
don't know like the the way that that
really allows for so many things to
sneak back up on you I think is is
really nicely handled I don't know there
there's there's so much to a movie like
this and yeah it's got those aspects
that are kind of cool but also those
aspects that make you think that are
authentic and harsh and difficult and
yeah it shows you kind of how much time
I guess kind of don't change I mean not
that we know the most about you know the
true ins and outs of crime and police
work and everything but it seems like
you know corruption and the attitude
about how to interact with crime and
things like that is always like under
debate and this is like the the most
age-old sort of set of characters
clashing with each other trying to
figure out just what to do about the
lawlessness that still you know exists
beneath the law you know yeah um but
yeah yeah really striking really classic
like I get why this is a classic and I
can tell I'm going to be kind of
reflecting on it yeah and also why
Denzel is so praised for this film as
well yeah yeah yeah a lot of great work
across the board so what did you guys
think let us know your thoughts what are
your favorite moments from the film
what's your Insight on it do you were
you there when it dropped I got to
imagine this was a very formative film
for a lot of people and uh and yeah just
to to give some praise too again to
Antoine fuka like I really liked the
direction the way they shot it the way
they really used perspective and they
really used the shadows and the Heat and
just so much of that authent like it
this movie felt really well lived in and
again that comes from all sides but
really you need like this is one of
those movies that comes from the magic
of having like a beautiful blend of a
writer director and cast you know
scenario really firing on a cylind be a
collaborative so yes leave us your
thoughts gang leave a like on the video
and we will catch you next time for
another piece of
Cinema much love and uh and and don't do
crime